it's chef ludo lefeve and natasha legend  thank you  thank you  okay natasha yes or as luda will you say  natasha's name natasha  don't  every time you say it in the show it  makes me so happy  i am loving the show  it's different you guys have a fresh  take on a cooking show i'm so into the  premise uh yeah so basically it's six  chefs each six new chefs every episode  and it's sort of like a culinary  whodunit so there's they're they're  trying to impress ludo with their dishes  but what they don't realize is that one  of them is a rat and they're there to  sabotage  all of the dishes so if  ludo likes the food then the team gets  the money but  if he thinks it's disgusting then the  rat will get the money and so you kind  of like follow along and we followed  alongside  [Applause]  [Music]